[Musique]
rogner directement dans la crise
oui stéphanie qui t'aiment beau aimerait
bien plus à l'aise avec la cuisine c'est
sûr que j'ambitionne pas d'être la
cuisine est un guerrier
j'ambitionne pas ça est ce que j'ai
envie de ça non ça dépend
et puis je l'assumé oui mais pourquoi
j'aimerais un peu combattre certaines
craintes
si des glaces est blanchi sautez vous
faire suer un aliment vous donne des
sueurs froides
vous n'êtes pas seul comme des jets avec
certaines choses monter les blancs en
neige tamisée tous ces phénomènes des
chefs où on utilise les termes
techniques le s'assemblent le wall trade
compliqué qui on a l'impression qu'il
faut absolument être un chef réputé dans
un grand restaurant pour un capable de
cuisiner alors que tout le monde lui
cuisiner agronome et fermière véronique
bouchard a écrit cuisiner sans recette
pour amener de la simplicité en cuisine
il est venu passer un après midi avec
stéphanie à des légumes de saison
carottes des traces le chinois china war
wel chine apporte comme j'avais que je
pense qu'il faut se réapproprier la
cuisine comme étant une activité qui a
du sens et qui pour être agréable aussi
qu'on peut faire ça mais en amoureux
entre amis
d'où une perte de connaissance de tous
les savoir faire culinaire de comprendre
les principes de base de la cuisine
donner les cours d'économie familiale et
dans certaines familles à savoir l'eau
ne s'est pas transmis pour diverses
raisons il y en a pour qui les livre de
recettes ça va très bien c'est parfait
il y en a qui vont aimer regarder des
émissions télé moi c'est pas du tout mon
cas je trouve ça mais encore plus de
pression des réseaux sociaux
ça peut avoir certains bons effets pour
stimuler notre curiosité le goût
d'apprendre à cuisiner mais en même
temps le revers de la médaille c'est que
parfois on va se mettre trop de pression
pour arriver à des résultats
et puis on va se comparer la docteur
julie st-pierre explique que souvent
c'est l'anxiété de performance qui est
au coeur du problème s'est inquiété le
peut dans les cas graves nous amener
même certaines inhibitions du goût de
cuisiner créé physiquement des réactions
l'extrême de tout ça c'est de vraiment
avoir un blocage ou est-ce que ça peut
devenir le vraiment une relation de 1 an
vers la cuisine de peur mais comme une
phobie
on va se faire mais petit robot
traitantes déjà fait ça génialement on
est beaucoup dans le stress de ne pas
être capable de réaliser un repas qui
apprécié par les gens autour de nous et
ça bien sûr que ça va nous amener à
surconsommer des choses qui sont déjà
préparées la coriandre j'espère que tu
aimes la cornouaille en sept ans comme
une baguette magique quand on parle des
dagues et d'ingrédients qui son goût
turquie sont savoureux on peut faire des
combinaisons assez simple et facile
ça va goûter bon tous les soirs et le
chou piste à une autre claque on
pourrait être pourrait maintenant dans
la hiérarchie tu vas m'indiquer comment
couper on peut rire de nous rater comme
on peut dire waouh c'est vraiment un
chef-d'oeuvre on est fiers de nous et ça
rend les choses encore meilleures
cuisines et ça prend un minimum de temps
le temps de consulter des recettes de
l'avs ai coupé cuir un service il faut
être dispose il faut sentir qu'on est
dans un moment où est ce que on vit
moins de stress qu'à l'habitude à l'oeil
de deux trois minutes rouler un rouleau
plus facile que l'on croit suffit
d'avoir confiance donc rempli côté celui
là un autre truc pour se faciliter la
vie
avoir des ingrédients de base toujours
disponible et j'ai toujours de lui le
frh ouais on a notre huile qu'on utilise
pour faire une vinaigrette qu'on utilise
pour faire la cuisson qu'on utilise pour
faire notre marianne m mais cette huile
a comme on la consomme rapidement aussi
elle est plus fraîche elle risque
moindre en cire donc aussi dans une
optique de contrer le gaspillage
alimentaire est aussi de réduire la
facture d'épicerie de partir de quelques
ingrédients de base
si internet peut ajouter un stress de
performance c'est peut aussi donner un
coup de main trois ingrédients de notre
armoire plusieurs idées de recettes
je mets toujours recette facile à côté
parce que j'ai pas envie d'embarquer
dans un truc
cette chasse il les propositions sortent
avec internet c'est tellement facile de
pouvoir consulter 4,5 j'accepte pour
comprendre un peu le principe d'avoir et
il ya des petits livres saints chrétiens
oui ça va ma jolie c'est bon comment
restaurant il suffirait de rajouter une
touche de call of duty
on mange trois fois par jour pour toute
la vie qu'on aime ou on n'aime pas ça on
doit apprendre à se nourrir c'est
essentiel annabi quand véronique est
parti on a demandé à stéphanie comment
s'était passée son expérience c'est
quand les premières impressions première
impression d'une personne qui a su me
mettre à l'aise bien su être à l'écouté
et ça ça je pense a pas de prix et
quelques jours après notre passage
stéphanie nous envoyait ses images
on y voit entre autres des dizaines de
rouleaux ou rouler elle s'est finalement
amusé
[Musique]